how are you tired hey rich are you done
a good night with you hey last time you
you were on the show you you had lighter
pockets they got heavier pockets and
that's a good thing that's a good thing
so the good thing I'll just secure my
kids you can for sure now you know I
mean obviously that is a measure of your
success we all we all measure success
with with that what we make now I'm
wondering what this contract means to
you overall in your life in your journey
tyrant well you know which obviously you
talked quite a bit you know i paid the
biggest thing is you know everything i
overcame you know i'm on think it was
necessarily you know about the money or
you know even proving the people that I
can play football it was more about me
being consistent on the football field
being a true professional and I've been
fortunate enough to come to organization
where they already had certain guys in
place one by Patrick Peterson al Arif is
Joe so it was really up in me to follow
God meeting they did a good job on
teaching you the ropes and I I guess
this is the one for everybody well but
there there are many guys in the NFL I
mean the NFL is in many ways littered
with guys who have had trouble pasts
certainly when it involves controlled
substances and then they're surrounded
by guys who are of high character and
they still don't get it and tyron you
you're you are a remarkable individual
in that regard what what has it been
about your makeup your journey that you
have been able to put your foot in the
ground and pivot in your life the way
that you have well you know rich I just
really I'll try to be consistent you
know I'm even going back to LSU i will
put together through three or four good
months and then i'll slip up you know
what i mean i'll put together another
three or four a good much and then i'll
slip up again and all those things kind
of add up so for me it was just about
being consistent Lance you're being true
to my responsibilities and holding
myself accountable you know at times you
know we start on that
you know we don't have anybody to answer
to everyone tends to answer to us and
I'm so I've been fortunate enough not to
really be blessed man and God has really
had some patience with me when you
mention LSU I don't know if you heard
what Coach Miles said on Wednesday about
your contract he called the 2012
dismissal of you buy him from the Tigers
program quote unquote that's one of the
worst things I've ever done is what he
said what do you think when you hear
that well well if I can go back I would
you know but at the end of the day rich
I think it really helped me out because
like I said you know at times you know
we reach these certain levels of success
and people just tend to give us second
third fourth chances and also I was
grateful that Les Miles really put his
foot down and suspending me and kick me
off his football team because that car
open wide and that sitting out football
an entire year man it was depressing so
long I was all efficient to get back to
it and I was really unfortunate landing
blessed that the Cardinals took a test
on in a fair round Tyrann Mathieu
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
what would you say to josh gordon if you
have a moment for him plug it's that
consistency I was just speaking out
Lando obviously he's a talented player
on that corner the best receivers in the
National Football League but I think if
he can be consistent on with itself and
be truthful itself and understand his
responsibilities and hold itself
accountable we can't we can't say that
it's our coaches out to hold us
accountable or a solid therapist or
counselor jobs all us accountable that's
actually our job every didn't wake up
and if you can do that you'll be great
and it's not just football though I mean
and again everybody situation is
different your situation Tyron is
different from from Gordon's and and
there are many people who are listening
to the show right now I'm sure would
love to know what what is the secret to
finding that consistency though it's you
know you say that you just want to be
consistent and you're trying it but it
can't be that easy as just saying it
right yeah yeah you right rich but for
me I would beat up so much man you know
obviously you know the string of failed
drug test I have a LSU and you know just
being black about
do you know having family members turn
their back on me having friends well at
least I got there with my friends you
know guys call all those type of
situations I was just tired man and I
always just sick of living that kind of
life I was sick of letting people down
and most importantly I was super letting
myself down so who's in your who's in
the circle of trust for you right now
hello like I said then I've been
something very blessed by an unfortunate
you know to really have a coach like
bucerias you know to have guys like
Patrick and Larry so I've been extremely
blessed and fortunate because a lot of
guys you don't have that you know they
don't have guys like Larry Fitzgerald or
guys like Patrick Peterson on the team
they're kind of just anybody ourselves
so I've been really blessed night Tyrann
Mathieu joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show when do I see you back on a
football field let's get into this well
hopefully the next couple weeks I'll be
out there practicing but I feel great
rich um it's been going great I'm I've
been grinding really hard landing on we
got high expectations over here in
Arizona so I'm going to get my teammate
bounce but at the same time I don't want
to rush back out there and not be a
hundred percent because those guys know
me as one kind of one type of player and
I want to be that kind of guy when I
come back yeah what was it like I know
the answer the question but I'll ask it
anyway I mean what was it like watching
the playoffs last year no knowing right
in the back your mind yeah I mean it was
the pressing I never still was so tough
because you know we understood our
expectation that we actually lived up to
him and you know to get to the playoffs
and me not been available and you know
us as a team not really playing out
that's kind of football um you know the
air come we just sucked up out of us and
both that we can rebound from that we
can shake back from that which I know we
will cuz you know we got some great team
leaders we've got a great culture staff
to know so we're looking forward to the
season oh no we're gonna treat this one
like it's do or die and what is arian
saying to you guys what is he saying day
and damn well you know ba use a lot of
curse words but you know uh well I don't
leave somebody's in his parking spot we
saw that we saw that legs and uh you
know but I think the biggest thing would
be a is you know is to forget about last
season you know obviously you want to
take certain things from last season
because
you know that that's what we are you
know will change back and face adversity
taking that can set expectations for
ourselves an accomplice to accomplish
those expectations so for him he's all
about team he wants us to understand
that we're all in this thing together
and uh he had high expectations for us
and he demands a lot out of us now
you're mentioning about how tiring that
you've got Peterson on your team and
Larry on your team and how they've
helped for me uh sort of a safety net
for you in a way how about you being
part of somebody else's safety net
somebody like Robert Kim DG who comes
into the league with a lot of question
marks about what was going on with him
at the collegiate level what can you
tell me about your role with him and how
he's adjusting I know he's got a high
ankle sprain right now yeah but what
what can you tell me about that well you
know I'm i met Robert of the pre-draft
is that you know kind of fell in love
with the guy um but he's one of those
guys that's gonna shoot you straight
he's very honest and I'm like I told the
biggest anger here which was the biggest
thing with me was consistency you know
be consistent be responsible I hold
yourself accountable I'm not gonna call
your phone every single day and check up
on me that's your job to do but I'm here
for you and I think he understands that
and then he's getting to get back on the
football so he's been handling into
rehab very very well you know what the
high ankle sprain not being able to
practice he keeps the smile on his face
and I think that's the most important
thing have fun with this doesn't man be
responsible hold yourself accountable
because you're gonna make plays on the
football field because you're that type
of talent who's the toughest receiver
that you've gotta either cover or be
part of defending time well you know I
garla you know at my first assignment
was to check ladders jello first day I
showed up and I was all mad it's like a
Hall of Fame so that was pretty tough
only at the last season going up against
that telling you around a couple plays
he definitely wonder better receivers in
his leaks and also i really look forward
to those type of match ups and i look
forward to dealing with these bigger
tight ends i love i love that matchup
for some reason she just you know i got
this little missenden rich you know i
just love it you know I i just love i
really have enjoyed you know getting to
know you Tyron you know in the times
that we've chatted
um and and seeing how you've developed
into a man you know an a man in this in
this man's league and I just remember at
the combine where you're working out
Dion was telling us just don't sleep on
this kid just don't throw him out just
because of what happened at LSU that he
is redeeming himself and he's got
ability that's all he kept saying every
single one of us Mayock me every single
one of us and then to see you actually
realize that it's just awesome it really
is siren yeah Austin thank you without
the blessing I appreciate it you bet
thanks for calling in to the show and
let's chat well when you get back out on
the field okay okay oh well respected
loved it you got it you got it the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience